the release of Palestinian prisoners
earlier this year under the peace plan
brokered by US Secretary of State John
Kerry the freeing of more than 100
inmates in four waves is meant to
bolster trust between the two sides but
at the same time as the two previous
releases Israel has also announced plans
to build new Jewish homes on land the
Palestinians say is there's Israeli
defense minister Moshe Ya'alon says it
is Israel's right to build according to
their understandings and agreements with
the Americans but even in Israel the
settlement plans have vocal opponents
what is clear to the international
community and to many Israelis into the
Palestinians is not clear to Netanyahu
building and promoting of settlements is
devastating for the two-state solution
and counterproductive a Palestinian
spokesman said the settlements were
illegal under international law and a
deliberate attempt to talk pdx well the
heaviness of the settlements activities
are not in line with the American
efforts to reach peace the settlement
plan tenders are not the way to reach
peace these activities are looking for
the failure of the American efforts less
alone Israel seems determined to press
ahead with settlement building previous
peace talks ran aground on the same
issue in 2010